welcome everybody to another entrepreneur AMA we're playing some
League of Legends we're answering your business questions join I have to join
the game wow we got salt happening everywhere here I'm watching the twitch
chat and trainer six are my our newest member of the team here is spreading
salt and twitch and J rise one of our oldest members here is that is like
yelling at me to join the game well your comment your comment about you
don't need your friend yeah Rishi was laughing at me in the gratitude stream
this morning so you guys man we need we need to press the reset button and have
a great day anyway now it's all jokes it's all jokes I know we're all we're
all in this to have a good time so Rishi my co-host welcome back love it
TGIF love I like the TGIM in the chat that was that was instead level so
Mondays has become my new Friday I like it what's what's in the cup today what
do we got work we're continuing with our fantasy in here I've got another
and then today I'm feeling a cup of a cup of awake I know you didn't get good
sleep last night Evan but I'm feeling it's weird I feel like I I'm really
awake right now all right I don't know I love it wow I love it I didn't say I
wasn't awake I just said that I didn't get a good sleep oh okay no that's good
I'm feeling it I like it I like it I'll have to channel some of that Rishi energy
into my Teemo play today and see how we do we got a streak going where's they know
we got a streak going Zaino our two games I know where's they know I'm the
chat he's not there yeah well we we had a comeback yesterday trainer six and J
rise carried the early game and I carried the late game we made it happen
all right well we're waiting for our game to start while we do that why don't
we hit up some questions what do we got love it let's go so first question today
comes from Natalie Natalie says yeah Natalie is really wanting to learn
English and has forced for quite some time and she I know this is it may not
be specifically an entrepreneur question but she wanted to know you know what you
thought about how she can use the internet to learn English and she said
internet only so interesting question you know there are multiple channels on
YouTube that are specifically for teaching people English so for sure
check those out but it reminded me of when I was learning Spanish my favorite
way to learn Spanish was to watch the telenovelas so the the Spanish soap
operas so yeah it was fun it was like it was like for me it was fun to be able to
watch Spanish not in the context of necessarily like a classroom but in to
hear actual conversational Spanish and have some drama of the storyline of the
telenovela at the same time so maybe you want to look at YouTube has some English
TV shows and what just watch just watch some funny English TV shows cup of what
cup of drama yeah drama llama oh wow it's Friday drama llama so yeah watch
something I see I think if you can learn English conversational English it's
better than trying to go you know just study these book attacks I think if you
have a show that you really like to watch and it's in English that's a great
place to start yeah I agree I think if you can do the thing that you are
naturally that you naturally love doing you'll get way better results and trying
to force yourself to read textbooks we're in the game and I have jungle
Jerry's has top and trainer six has hot lane so get some Timo jungle happening
coming on hopefully this this actually touches a personal cord for me because
when my mom came to I mean I grew up learning English I grew up in Canada I
was born here but my mom wasn't she was born in Italy and when she came here she
learned English by watching TV shows I don't know what they were soap operas
but there are these TV shows and why it strikes a personal cords because there's
been a number of people who have commented on my videos to say that
they're learning English by watching my videos and it just yeah it's like a full
circle moment knowing that you know this is how my mom learned English and now
other people like I'm able to help the next the next generation of people who
are trying to learn English so I imagine like a young version of my mom coming
over here and learning about the video so the eyes pretty pretty meaningful for
me I think back to the Tim Ferriss example where he was trying to learn
Japanese and he was reading textbooks and it was just super boring and just
memorizing and he couldn't really get into it and the way that he learned was
by reading karate instructional manuals in Japanese because he loved karate and
he wanted to learn karate in Japanese and so he would force himself to figure
out what those characters meant because he wanted to learn the art of karate and
so you know he loves karate Rishi loves her her dramas exactly you're right you
know the soap the soap opera but the cheese is good I actually had two sisters
growing up and we I watched some soap operas in my day too so the older sister
controlling the the remote control with one TV in the house so I have I have a
little bit of young and restless and bold and beautiful knowledge to dish out
but not the Spanish ones so yeah finding the thing that like what interests you
if you like you're on my channel if you like entrepreneurship that could be
helpful to you you know I I speak normal English I've I've what do I need to do
what are you talking oh it's not streaming can you guys hear me yep it's
only audio right now and it's a black screen oh I don't know I'm seeing it in
the open whatever podcast version 2 oh I really enjoy watching yeah I don't know
it's uh it's all loaded on my end I don't know what the no it'll stop the
whole thing oh whatever podcast it up I just okay yeah I mean I my English is
pretty solid so if you're learning for me you know I don't really make a ton of
grammatical mistakes hopefully at least and in my mom her English is insane her
English is better than than 99% of people honestly like she really spent
the effort to get amazingly good at it lost all any you know I lost any traces
of an accent just by you know watching TV shows so I think that's definitely a
good start I think there are I agree with Risha there's a lot of YouTube
channels to that break it down that break down English and give you a word
of the day or how to use sentences and and there's a lot of there's some humor
and fun and going into a lot of them now so it's not just textbook boring that
the new generation of people who are up on YouTube that those could be some fun
videos but I think the key thing is like anything you have to find a way to make
it fun you have to find a way to make it enjoyable if you do that you're much
more likely to stick with it just like a workout routine or an exercise routine
you know if you hate swimming but you love playing basketball with your
friends then just make it easy on yourself and go play basketball with
your friends right you're still getting a good workout so whatever that applies
to learning English then I would take it up the other thing I would look at for
using internet specifically is there are some sites where you can connect with a
language buddy where you can have conversations so what language is this
person speak or do we know?
um yeah she didn't mention where she's from
okay he wants to yeah well whatever so like say it's Spanish you know there are
English-speaking native speakers who want to learn Spanish and the idea is you get on a
call once a week for an hour and half an hour of it is in Spanish and you help
them and half an hour is in English and they help you and being able to practice
I think as well can be really helpful with someone who's understanding with
someone who's learning too and I think it makes you feel not so bad because
when you're talking to somebody and their Spanish sucks and then you're
gonna talk to them you don't feel so bad about your English being bad oh so I
would look up some of those language buddy websites and see if you make some
connections
awesome and then we've got some people in the chat that have lost audio it says
offline for some people on on my end it says idle so I don't know that is mean
you're not even streaming anymore but want to make sure
okay well let's record and we're going to put on YouTube all this was still
recording and we'll put it up it's just not happening on Twitch gotcha I didn't
know if it was also going to lose your audio or whatever yeah no this should
all be still good for for YouTube okay next question comes from Eugene Eugene
and Eugene Eugene Eugene okay yeah and Eugene is from Croatia and he wants help
on his idea he doesn't really go into the idea but he says we're living in a
country where things like that are not possible to do we don't have the
requested knowledge to make the application oh it's an app idea okay so
it's an app but he doesn't go into what the actual app does so he says we're
living in a country where it's not possible to do things like that we don't
have the knowledge to make the app and we don't have the money to pay for the
marketing and other stuff that comes with that sort of thing he wants to
share his app idea with you because I think he feels like there's no one in
Croatia who who's able to help or give him the knowledge he needs to kind of
proceed with this idea um okay so
respectfully oh oh she's awake it's Friday
love is coming respectfully really truly and I mean this what came to mind is
this on fire quote by sir EC Evan Carmichael and it says we don't have the
money the connections or the support but we don't make excuses did I say that
you did say that I love that I love that that that's one of my my retweeted Evan
quotes so but I also say it was like so much love because you know I get I get
how we all can fall into these mindsets of I'm disadvantaged because of XYZ and
I can't do it but I really it's so freeing when you find out that you are
limitless and you are only limited by your own mindset so I what I really
respect about route Eugene is that he's asking he's he is trying to get
somewhere with someone who he knows knows which is you Evan and so I
appreciate the effort but I also think that it's so important to recognize that
whether it's Croatia or anywhere else in the world there have been people in
every single place of the world that has been and you know considered in the
eyes of whoever you know a place that you can't do this you can't do that and
people have risen above that and made away so I think the real issue here is
first got to be about his beliefs around why he can't do what he needs to do
and yeah that's kind of what I want to share I love it yeah I agree man like
you have a computer you have a phone you can program so I need like you have what
you need already to succeed you just got to start doing the work if you don't
know how to program that might be a different issue and you got to find
someone to help you create it and maybe it is a little tougher in Croatia you
know but maybe you don't limit yourself to just Croatia like hanging out in
online communities so you can connect with people have made partnerships and
friendships and arrangements just being a part of believe nation people who've
done collaboration I think of Rishi and she's done collaborations with Jen and
with Tamra and like I don't know have you guys ever even met Rishi no not in
person yeah it's almost weird like I've never met Rishi in person either here we
are doing a daily stream together you know so you could be part of communities
the world is so much smaller now that you can get access and you can connect
with the right people you just got to figure out what it is that you need
what's the skill set do you need a programmer do you need the marketing
person do you need you know do you have the idea fully flushed out what do you
need to get to where you need to go and just stop blaming your country man stop
blaming the lack of resources you have like it will never help you got to go
out and start taking some action on it and that you know that sucks to hear but
also is empowering because people have done things built built apps built
companies with less than you already have right now you are fully capable of
doing this if you just believe in yourself and start taking some action on
it and like we all have these things that we say we can't do this because of
whatever reason and that's that's honestly those limiting beliefs have
always been what have held all of us back have held me back every major
breakthrough I've had has come from crushing one of my limiting beliefs and
so you just got to get to work in terms of the marketing like app marketing is
becoming less and less important what you need to have is something that
people will want to use every day like will somebody open up your app and use
it every day if you have built that kind of product you don't need any marketing
like what was snapchats marketing budget when they were starting up probably zero
or close to zero right and that's most apps like the ones you may see on TV you
know Game of War or whatever a lot of these guys don't start spending money on
ads until they've they've already kind of hit most of the mainstream and now
they're trying to hit the bigger audience too so you just need to build
something that people want to use every day that's it like you'll win if people
are watching you every single just like my youtube channel just like most
products now that have social built into them like an app like for me the answer
to grow my channel or Rishi to grow her channel or any of you guys to grow your
channels is not how do I market it more it's how do I make it something that
people want to come back to every single day if you do that you win and so you
just need to design a crazy app that people want to use every day I don't
know what it's all about and I'm not the right partner I'm not in the app
development game I have enough going on with what I'm doing now that I don't
want to be doing apps I appreciate the reach out and the respect there but if
you have the technical skills then just start coding and if you don't then you
need to find that local or online person you can connect with to make it happen
and just start no excuses like Rishi said how did you start that response
Rishi I was geared up for oh oh I said respectfully respectfully you know that's
something big is coming because Rishi doesn't show disrespect so there's
either something coming I liked it it was like respected sir yesterday
respected sir yeah all right um great great then Biniyam is our next question
all right Biniyam yeah and Biniyam actually in line with this app question
is the creator of an app called what's hot what's hot and it yeah what's hot he
created it created it in his parents house when he was attending University
of Washington and what's at what's hot is that app where you get the hottest
news as soon as it happens that's kind of like a you know hot hot news anyway
so he's wanting ideas on how to promote the app and would be extremely helpful
for him if you had any ideas on on promotion so I kind of think you just
answered it in the last question you may Biniyam also want to check out
episode 14 of this League of Legends stream because we had several questions
about app marketing and and how to be more effective with your apps and so you
might want to check out episode 14 for sure as well as there are many videos on
Evans channel but but I think yeah I mean again it comes back down to if
your app is amazing if your app is great if you're more focused on creating an
app that really is amazing you get those small amount of people who just are
super fans and then they share it and share it and share it I and I think I
shared with one of the other callers or the other questions in episode 14 that I
love it when an app has great customer service like if there's someone who's
already been using what's hot and they've been giving you feedback about
it you know I would pay attention to the feedback that I'm getting and really
listen to your users and see how you can improve upon anything that your current
users are saying about what's hot
I like it I agree yeah I mean we did cover this pretty recently but you know
the two things I would add that maybe a little more context one would be if I
was doing any kind of outreach or marketing the people that would target
would be influencers in the space so someone who loves news is a news junkie
like it's not me I don't follow many news websites I think most news is
pretty negative and honestly not really relevant to what I'm doing so I just
typically ignore like you know my parents they watch the nightly news 11
o'clock every night they you know need to be in the know that's not me and so I
wouldn't I don't I don't care about that so much I know a lot about a little bit
so you know you want to talk about entrepreneurship you want to talk about
salsa you're talking League of Legends you know I know a lot about that stuff
anything else forget it and I'm okay with that yeah but you got to find you
those people who who think that that's crazy right like you have to know and be
on top of every latest trend right those are those are people who are gonna love
what you're doing and reach out to them and show them the app that you you have
and see if there's an interest there the app though has to work it's got to be
good right if you show me an app about entrepreneurship I'm naturally
interested because I want to help entrepreneurs and I'm always curious but
if it's no good like that's it I'm not it's super hard to get a second chance
to say hey look at my app a second time because the first version was really
crap well they're like well thank you for wasting my time that first time
around you know it's like it's hard to get that second chance so it's the
victor leaf I think our guy are we're 4v5 here again our mid laner one of our
teammates is gone oh no he's back okay I think he just maybe went to the bathroom
so what I would focus on is looking at the the people that you have now getting
them to use it every single day like how many people are on your app right now
and are they loaded it on a consistent basis because people will share if
people love your thing people are gonna share constantly so it's really just
getting to that point where you have those hundred people 50 people 25 people
whatever it is who love what you're doing I can't wait to tell everybody
about it and instead of focusing on getting new people in which is a which
is I know it's a temptation focus on making sure that the people that you
have are really happy yeah great that's it I'm excited I'm excited too so
Michael is asking Evan I'm having a hard time believing in my dream starting my
dream of starting my own business I want to step out and bet on myself but I'm
afraid any advice you could give me any potential videos of yours to watch you
you feeling this one enough you did you want to chime in first or no I like I
like the counter punching like I like the I like the reacting I like seeing
what you have to say and then I either you know say something similar or don't
I don't even know what I'm gonna say yet until you finish so I'm excited okay
waiting for the Rishi wisdom to drop here so Michael I guess I can just share
that my story with starting Rishi Cup TV I you know I even though I have a lot of
experience with like performing arts and doing things in front of people for me
you know obviously YouTube channel if it you have to share yourself regularly
with people and so even though I'd had a lot of experience with that sort of
thing Rishi Cup TV was like the first thing where I was doing my thing like I
wasn't I wasn't going to be kind of supporting someone else's dream it was
going to be my dream and man the fear I had prior to doing this was pretty
significant I mean I remember there'd be night like I was preparing the launch
you know and like I never done YouTube before I there was a lot of things I've
never done before and I was just like I'd wake up sometimes the middle of the
night just like what the heck like I can't do this and what what if I do this
and I completely you know all these what ifs and so one of the things that helped
me with that fear was you know what can I once I do this what's something I can
do every day in in the state of fear the fear didn't go away but what's
something I can do every day where I can create momentum but I'm also not taking
such a huge leap that it's not sustainable so like for me that looked
like putting out my very first video believe it or not was a calm almost like
a comedy video about fried chicken which in hindsight is funny because like
people would not have understood that I don't think at all but like for me it
was my first video and it was a video that I knew if I put it out there I was
gonna enjoy it but I also knew it was going to be sustainable because I wasn't
taking this huge leap that would put me in a state of fear that that would be
paralyzing if that makes sense so I believe in doing deaths that are small
enough to get momentum or big enough to make to get momentum but small enough to
not sabotage yourself where where you you kind of freak yourself out even more
and then you like don't ever want to do it again so take risk but I think it
should be calculated risk where you know you can you can get to a place where the
fear is manageable and then as you continue in your momentum I think you
get more confident and yeah so do it afraid but also be be kind of calculated
I think about the risk that you take so you know you can continue in it awesome
well my team is struggling a bit here we have 16 deaths and six kills I'm doing
okay I'm at two two kills and no deaths but and an assist but I've got to I've
got it I've got to help out my team a little more here so we can turn this
thing around listen fear is normal I've done a number of videos on fear if you
just go to my channel in search fear you'll see a bunch of them all of them
I think are worth watching fear is normal it's understanding that I'm not
I'm not the guy who gets up and say is don't be afraid I think I think that's
wrong I think you feel the fear and you do it anyway I think that's much more
approach that I kind of believe in and try to take myself I think when when
you're like I think fear is also a good sign like if you have no fear in your
life that means you're living your life so safe that you're not doing anything
special you're not really living up to your true potential
Jaira's is stressing out what's going on here a lot of deep breathing happening
from the other side of the room breathing is good deep breathing is good
too so fear is good fears means that you're you're you're stepping outside
your comfort zone the things that helped me with fear listen I'm still
afraid to like it I'm not immune to fear I'm not I'm not some you know like if I
stop being afraid of stuff then that's that's not great either even yesterday I
was doing an interview with with Chase Jarvis who's one of the best
photographers in the world built this huge company around training and and I
was a little nervous getting in you know before that call and it went well like
it was an amazing interview I had a lot of fun he enjoyed it the the crowd that
watched live enjoyed it but I still had a little bit of butterflies before going
it going in on the call wanted to make sure it was a good interview mm-hmm so
it's it's good like you need to have that in your life I think so in terms of
combating that the couple things that have helped one is just finding a way to
start smaller whatever it is that you want to do there's a smaller way to do
it so look at look at your big idea your big vision and then just see okay I want
it I want to go from A to Z but how do I start from A to B like what's the B step
if if Z is the the final you know step what's what's the B what's like the
smallest little thing that I can do because you know what that small little
thing that's not so scary that's not so scary like if you're afraid of getting
married going on one date that that's not so scary the dates not so scary the
marriage might be scary where you are now but is that not a good analogy am I
failing that I just know I just love that you always give her I feel I feel
like we need to have a relationship segment on your channel Evan because
you've always got great really oh well just the idea of like trying to bring
it to something non-business yeah entrepreneurs you know the it's hard
being entrepreneur maintaining relationships too so yes if you're
afraid of you know if you're afraid of that last big step don't worry about
making it some huge step there's a smaller way to get started go and focus
on that that's where you'll have success and it's not as not as big a fear to do
that and then you realize you realize that most big initiatives are really
just a accumulation of small initiatives added up my team is hurting hard here I
got to figure out how I can help with we're 23 kills a death sorry and six
kills 23 to six is yeah yeah I gotta help out more somehow I'm trying I'm
trying later I says it's over I'm not happy about that oh they're doing a
surrender yep oh they got shut down so that's the first thing is making it
smaller makes finding a smaller version to get started the other thing the other
thing I would say is what's helped me push through fear is the the bigger fear
of regret that whatever my my fear of you know getting on stage or starting
my company or making that phone call or whatever it is that you're afraid of
doing right now I try to look look at my look look my life I try to look at my
life you know I'm a hundred years old looking back or maybe like 160 because
we're gonna live that long you know when I get there I can look out that
far and think well I regret not doing this like that idea that you have will
you regret that you didn't take a chance that you were afraid and if and if it's
yes then that often gives me the courage to go forward and and to do it so I
don't know if that helps but those two things I found super helpful at least
for me and there's tons of videos again so you guys I'd encourage you to go on
the channel and and just search here and you'll find a whole bunch of videos that
that can be helpful to you you want to know something really fascinating I do
I like fascinating things yeah so I was watching this is I believe this is one
of your videos I talking about fear but Oprah was mentioning in an interview
that during her literally her entire career as the talk show host that part
that portion of her career she said she literally never felt afraid of doing her
shows and then when she started her Oprah Winfrey Network there was one
morning or one middle of the night she woke up and she literally felt like she
had this weight on her and it was like she almost couldn't breathe and she was
like well what is this and she said that what you know like what she heard and
response was this is fear and so anyway I thought it was interesting that she
never felt fear I mean at least in the context of doing what it was that she
was doing as a as a talk show host she never felt fear I just thought that's
fascinating that someone can actually have that that opposite experience of
not being afraid because I feel like that has never been my experience yeah
and that's not it's not normal either and I wouldn't take that as the standard
practice and look at that and then make yeah I think the danger in looking at
that and looking at an outlier like that is then saying oh well she wasn't she
wasn't afraid why am I afraid what's wrong with me where right where you're
actually normal and it's okay to be afraid but it's it's okay to be afraid
but then you still have to do it right it's feeling the fear and doing it you
still got to go and do it mm-hmm mm-hmm don't blame the fear for not moving
forward just like you know our previous one about I go on in Croatia so I can't
do it right there's always an excuse there's always a reason why you can't do
something and the reasons are always logical and practical and they just make
sense so that's why it's so easy to to not chase your dream to not do the thing
that you're you should be doing okay so yeah yeah look okay next question comes
from Elodie Elodie Elodie um yeah Elodie says he is a 24 year old French woman
she lives in Ottawa Canada all right yeah shout out to ant city well that's
Toronto I guess but mm-hmm I just like Canada and she's addicted to your
channel all right thank you welcome yes yeah and she said she watched the video
the other day called show up okay and it was the one that featured Farrah Gray
okay and in that in that video you talked a lot about kind of what one
particular experience where you gave some entrepreneurs an opportunity they
all you know you'd spoken at a conference and then of course after the
conference they were like we want you to mentor us we want you to mentor us and
then you you kind of put yep you kind of put them through this process right so
she was inspired and she really really wants to take a step forward with your
guidance and so she's just wanting to you know somehow get get some additional
mentoring and just kind of reaching out
okay um what what does she need help well she she actually just is she
didn't really go into the sequence I'm sorry I want to make sure I'm I didn't I
don't think she went into too much detail with this one about what she
wants to do but I think she's just an aspiring entrepreneur and yeah I'm gonna
look into this and I'm gonna add some value and then look to make sure she
didn't get some more details yeah I mean I I just told someone the other day that
for me one of the things that I just appreciate mentorship I appreciate when
anyone has the this is just a way to honor you Evan you know you you are
definitely someone that I've I consider right now as a mentor and I appreciate
when anyone who has you know basically a huge impact doing a million things and
they have the sensitivity to give back to others in the process and and I see
that you are always passionate about just making an impact so for me what I
want to do always where I'm in any kind of situation where I want to learn from
someone else I want to add value to their life I want to be able to
contribute to help their mission what they're doing and so for me I just think
in general a lot of people can come into any relationship whether it's mentoring
and kind of come with a what can I get and I think that one of the keys is
always to think well what can I give so that's just kind of my valuable what I
have found a valuable key in being able to receive from people that you really
want to receive from and again you don't go into it with this mentality of
like I'm doing this so I can get something like I think you've kind of
already lost when you any relationship like any relationship should never be
about how can I be in relationships so that I didn't get like I don't just that
just to me somehow is the wrong foot to start off on but just start by being a
human and I love it start by being a human we got to quote that yeah just
like people are people like people at the end of the day just like be a human
and any like a you know I don't know I guess I think that sometimes we just we
we can lose our minds when it comes to certain things but I don't know I hope
that what I'm saying is coming across like like I when I came to Evan's
channel like I didn't come to have a channel with the intent of can I
eventually be this or that person you know it's like I just I really loved
what Evan was doing I believed in what he was doing I was inspired by what he's
doing and it was easy for me to then want to somehow like be a part of so
anyway yeah so you know listen I'm feeling the love thank you for the kind
of words and glad you're obsessed when I think about this it's really tied into
the last question about but the big projects versus the little ones when you
ask somebody for mentorship it's it implies a relationship right and there's
not gonna be you know people who will without knowing you just say yes I'm
gonna be your mentor if they take mentorship seriously and so your best
bet is to build up that kind of relationship so it's awesome that like
there's a support and you know love the channel and you know I very much
appreciate that bless you J rise I don't have smite we're fighting here all right
but what would have been a better start is really just to ask a question like I
feel bad that I can't help you because I don't know what your business is about
and I don't know what kind of guidance you need and all I know is that you're
looking for a mentor so the only thing that can really help is how to how to
better ask for a mentor because I think both of us are a little bit like we're
on this thing because we want to give value when I help you help all you guys
out and we get frustrated when we can't what's happening
Oh J rises in the middle of a big big thing happening here yeah so that that's
that's that's our frustration that's what we're that's what we're we want to
help you we want to see you get better we want to see your business grow and if
you for the next time and maybe come back like ask us ask us a question for
the next episode that we'd be happy to answer and then really it's if you get
something if you get something little you get one piece of advice the most
important thing when you're approaching somebody you want help is that you then
take that advice and apply it because the worst thing the worst feeling for a
mentor is that you're not helping like you're not taking action you're not
respecting their time you know if I if I take the time to answer a question and
give you what I feel is a really good answer and what you may need and then
you don't go do anything with it that's massively frustrating and then I don't
want I don't want to you know I don't want you coming back again with the same
question where you didn't take any action off the first one so if you're
reaching out to people and you're looking for help when you're you're
thinking how can you you know get to where you need to go I love it I think
reaching out is definitely a great idea but in terms of the execution oh we're
getting destroyed here in terms of the execution just starting small just
finding something that you can do on a small scale reach out with one question
recognize that it's that you appreciate their time and their advice and that
you'll take action off of whatever they give you whether that's with me or
there's other people that you look up to that you're trying to get advice and
wisdom from and then and then if you want to maintain a relationship you want
to build it somewhere else then then come back in a week or a month or two
months or six months or however long it takes you to actually take action for
for all of these people that were answering questions for you want to ask
another question we're happy to add we're happy to answer but we want to
feel like you're taking action you're ready to go to that next step so that's
my best yeah and and to I just wanna I thought I got back to the email just so
I make sure I didn't miss anything and yet just just so there is an information
about what she wants to do specifically but to her credit I just want to say
that in that video I think the it went specifically into I think the the
process that you had explained in the in the case of the other mentorship
requests was that they had the first thing that you told them to do was send
you an email so I think I think she's kind of just following maybe what the
video had shared about that other scenario so I think I just feel I have a
heart for this LED woman sweet woman I know she's really trying to do what she
thinks would be the next step to show up when another thing in that video was
talking about going after opportunity with a vengeance that was one of the
things that Sarah Gray had said it's like you got to show up and so it sounds
like she's hungry she's trying to show up the way that you know I'm going to
bat for a LED I want to I want to yeah okay well we lost GG oh we'll see what
the final sets are and yes and maybe if that video is taking out of context
because that video was not an open invitation say hey anybody just send me
an email and I'll help it was at a specific event where I was asked to come
in Toronto with the mayor of the city to mentor some young entrepreneurs and I
said that I would and the people approached me afterwards I said that I
would but they had to email me and it was a specific ask to those people to
say hey right that's the next step you need to email me and follow up not as a
general call to action but I mean a lot of that a lot of these a lot of these
questions that we're getting asked here are just some people emailing in and you
know I get tons of email and I started this series because I wanted to be able
to try to answer some of them and give back and add some value so maybe I had a
little bit of clarity around that too so my team lost we got stomped we were 47
deaths 16 kills I had I went I went seven two and five had seven kills only
two deaths five is so but I wasn't enough to help my team everybody else
was having a hard time I didn't I didn't step up enough to save them soon enough
so yeah so we lose very sad but I appreciate that we were able to help
some entrepreneurs and that's the win for the day well we'll we'll we'll see
when our next game comes up on Monday Rishi do you have final words setting
people into the weekend for what they should be doing yeah just I I guess I
really was touched as about what you said about fear of regret so whatever
you're doing this weekend keep that in mind if you're if you're dealing with
fear what would you rather have that fear of doing it and just seeing what
happens or would you rather live by the fear of regret of not doing it I thought
that was really powerful well thank you guys for joining have an amazing day
continue to believe whatever your one word is and we'll see you soon this
isn't on our twitch channel but it's going to youtube so I'm still glad we're
able to get it saved even though the result isn't great but the content is
is good for entrepreneurs so that's it guys we'll see you soon have a great
weekend